highlights on our agenda were to fishery
items first data collection and second
technical measures and we spoke about an
update on the market situation
especially in the dairy and pig meat
sectors let me start with the fisheries
better data means better science which
would in turn allow all of us to make
better decisions when managing fish
stocks and in order to facilitate a
prompt agreement with the european
parliament on this file we presented a
compromise which aims to clearly
implement the requirements of the
reformed common fisheries policy
regarding data collection and that
compromise was met with agreements or
the council endorsed the presidency
compromising now there's a clear mandate
to start negotiating negotiating with
the european parliament Commissioner
Vela presented a proposal for new
technical measures framework its aim is
to deliver on the key objectives of the
reformed como Fisheries Policy our
discussion of the proposed today set up
a constructive examination process this
item will return our on our agenda in
the coming months this afternoon we
spoke about the market situation in the
main European agricultural sectors
notably the dairy pig meat and fruit and
vegetables sectors we concluded that the
Commission is doing its part in
delivering on the meshes that we agreed
upon last month and now the council
needs to quickly adopt the modification
to the fixing regulation on aids and
refunds that is needed for doubling
ceilings for skim milk powder and butter
I was very much able to update the
council in relation to even to
regulations that have been implemented
as recently as today in respect to the
implementation of the article 2 22 of
the of the CMO which implements the
voluntary arrangements for production
patterns of milk in the European Union I
also claimed that the in the context of
the measures announced the 42 March that
the state aid rules are mean flexibly
applied in order to allow member states
to be able to use financial incentives
through that particular mechanism if
they wish to do so secondly we had the
visit a vice president Katainen to the
council as well today and where he was
discussing the role of the Younker funds
and the in other words the FC plan and
how it could help agriculture and a
green vestment i will be in a position
to take back to the Trade Commissioner
the concerns expressed by twenty
ministers today at our agricultural
meeting about not just the issue of the
timing of the Mercosur negotiations was
also the potential for tariff rate
quarters to be applied at this stage of
the negotiations everyone is in support
of trade [ __ ] outcomes and free trade
agreements but they are certainly
indications from the minister's today
that they would prefer to be more
strategic in relation to various
sensitive palate areas at the moment